[Applause]
inside sri lanka's most heavily guarded
building its new president was chosen
mps cast secret ballots to decide who
would succeed gotabe rajapaksa
he fled in a military plane last week
after tens of thousands of protesters
stormed his official residence
the prospect of ranil vikramasingha
succeeding rajapaksa had caused an
outcry from thousands who were demanding
that he too stepped down
but more than half the parliamentarians
ignored the protesters wishes
the time of being divided is over we had
48 hours of division now i'm asking
everyone to get together to discuss i'd
like to start discussions with all of
you from tomorrow
[Music]
many sri lankans are angry that a man
voted out of parliament in the last
election has become president he is the
defender of the rajapaksa family the
second reason is he doesn't have a
mandate to be a member of parliament at
least so we do not accept his
appointment
public opinion is opposed to this we the
trade unions are opposed to it the
people are opposed to it we are clearly
opposed to raniel's appointment this is
not the people's will it's a distortion
one of the first things wikrama singh
had did was thank the armed forces and
police
hundreds of security personnel secured
the parliament complex to ensure
wednesday's vote was not disrupted
analysts say his immediate challenge
will be to pull sri lanka back from the
brink of total disaster
a moderate parliamentarian in the
rajapaksa's slpp party told me the
election was a battle between money and
conscience protesters say given their
elected representatives did not reflect
their views when choosing their
candidate
they will continue to oppose the
presidency of runner vikrama singha
fernandez al jazeera colombo